m
marseille deuxième ville de france
forte de ses 850 mille habitants un
territoire immense grand comme deux fois
et demi paris ou 5 x lion une superficie
qui justifie la présence de pas moins de
quatre cent quarante quatre écoles
primaires publiques où sont scolarisés
73 mille élèves alors bien sûr dans la
cité phocéenne
on entendait parler de conditions
d'enseignement pas toujours glorieuses
de locaux vétustes
quand des parents d'élèves se mobilisent
est ici ou des syndicats enseignants
haussé le ton la relayés par des élus ou
la presse locale mais c'est libération
qui jette un pavé dans la mare en y
consacrant sa une le 2 février 2016
école à marseille
la honte de la république un titre choc
accompagnée d'un dossier de quatre pages
sur la situation
et ce n'est qu'un début les photos
afflux compilées par des syndicats ou
des médias locaux classe à moins de 15
degrés l'hiver rongeurs dans les
couloirs locaux insalubres
sol jonché de trous ou encore sanitaire
dans un état déplorable
pas question pour la municipalité de
laisser cette idée prospérer alors le
sénateur maire jean claude gaudin contre
attaque très rapidement et il est très
facile de prendre dans une école sur 444
ou dans deux écoles ou dans trois ce qui
ne va pas et de le mentionner d'une
manière extraordinaire
encore une fois c'est très excessif par
rapport à la réalité des choses
deux ou trois écoles seulement concerner
pas vraiment le sentiment de la
sénatrice maire des 15e et 16e
arrondissements samia ghali qui dit
dénoncer la situation depuis des années
sans avoir jamais été entendu comment on
peut deuxième ville de france
avoir des écoles qui ressemble aux
écoles et malheureusement de la misère
des écoles qui re ceux qui sont du
tiers-monde
voilà qui ressemble car monde mais ça
c'est pas acceptable dans la deuxième
ville de france
même une c'est une de trop habitués à
être pointés du doigt par la presse
nationale pour ses règlements de comptes
en série
la ville est cette fois accusée de
laisser certaines de ces écoles à
l'abandon pendant deux mois
nous avons enquêté sur cette polémique
m
cette fois le focus nationale est
pointée sur les écoles phocéenne c'est
qu'un cri d' alerte a résonné plus fort
que les autres
un cri sous forme de lettre envoyée à la
ministre de l'éducation nationale par
une enseignante des quartiers nord de la
ville
madame la ministre je vous écris cette
lettre parce que ma colère d'enseignante
m'empêche de vivre et pire encore de
travailler marseille quartiers nord une
de ces écoles en décrépitude où les
enseignants assez souvent en état de
survie psychiques ont pris l'habitude de
trouver normal les conditions que nous
imposons à nos élèves
je nous accusent d' aggraver les
inégalités sociales je nous accuse de
produire sciemment de l'échec scolaire
et des délinquants je nous accuse de
jouer avec la santé des enfants des
classes sociales les moins favorisées
je respecte trop mes élèves et leurs
parents pour trouver cela normal
un jeu nous accuse publié sur un blog
puis repris par un site d'information
locale un texte accompagné de photos qui
marque les esprits
c'est un élève que j'ai pris en photo
alors pas dans l'école où j'étais en ce
début d'année scolaire mais une autre
école des quartiers nord dans laquelle
je travaillais l'année dernière donc on
a un élève en doudoune qui essaye
d'écrire avec les doigts un peu court
certaines écoles dans ces quartiers là
sont laissés à l'abandon
et encore une fois ça c'est une photo
pour n'importe quel enseignant
marseillais qui a l'habitude de
travailler dans les quartiers nord c'est
une photo que tout le monde
enfin c'est un genre de photos que tout
le monde a son téléphone portable ça n'a
rien de surprenant des situations devenu
banal qui s'accumulent jusqu'au moment
où le vaste trop plein des bordes le
jour où une maman d'élève m'a demandé si
il ne valait pas mieux que sa fille
reste à la maison
les deux prochains jours en attendant
que le chauffage puisse être réparé si
on avait de la chance et que je me suis
entendu lui répondre oui effectivement
c'est mieux il vaut mieux qu'elle reste
à la maison parce qu'elle avait les
lèvres bleues en fin de journée je me
suis dit c'est pas possible
il aura fallu le relais de libération
pour que cette lettre envoyée en
novembre 2015 à najat vallaud belkacem
est enfin une réponse non la situation
n'est pas acceptable pour la ministre à
prendre le sujet des écoles marc faye
aide au sérieux asseyez-vous autour
d'une table et travaillons juste d'avoir
un certain nombre d'écoles qui sont dans
un état de délabrement sa nouvelle
rapportée par les parents l'aisne qui ne
va pas qui n'est pas acceptable dans
notre république pas acceptable dans
notre république
la phrase est lâchée jean claude gaudin
est pointé du doigt comme un mauvais
élève
pas question pour lui d'accepter ce
bonnet d'âne sans broncher la réplique
aura lieu lors du conseil municipal du 8
février
dans ce théâtre où les joutes verbales
n'ont rien à envier à du pagnol
le maire lâche ses coups et joue les
offusqués je n'avais jamais vu ça et
pourtant j'avais vu un grand quotidien
national qui se livrent une manipulation
des faits truqués tronquer et déformer
au mépris de toutes les règles de la
déontologie journalistique
c'est une honte pour ce journal un
gouvernement qui se vend entre
immédiatement dans l'exploitation de
cette campagne de presse sans doute
excité temps des élus toujours à vivre
de publicité dans une compétition
électorale un terme à la gauche c'est
une autre des photos que vous avez vues
elles vous plaisent pas c'est vrai bon
non plus à me plaisent pas moi aussi
j'ai pas envie j'aurais préféré qu'elle
ne soit pas là mais en même temps si
elles existent si les photographes l'ont
fait ces quelques spectacles au parc ça
existe je vous propose à tous élus aux
membres de la presse
d'effectuer des visites les visites que
vous voudrez dans les écoles que vous
voudrez quand vous voudrez nous montrons
ensemble dans un minibus et vous irez
voir exactement la réalité de ce que
vous prétendez dépeindre dans certains
articles et là vous comprendrez
aussitôt dit aussitôt fait les
journalistes sont invités à monter dans
le bus et même à choisir leur école avec
de faussaires de voyages scolaires
l'opération communication de la mairie
est en route
premier arrêt et surprise samia ghali
n'a pas manqué l'occasion de participer
à cette virée dans son secteur
face à elle aucun élu de la majorité
municipale mais des fonctionnaires pas
autorisées à s'exprimer
la sénatrice a tout le loisir de
torpiller l'opération communication de
la mairie
j'ai pas que les travaux de chauffage se
font pas ou les travaux que vos services
ne font pas tout non juste que en
matière de chauffage à des écoles où ça
dure plus longtemps que d'autres mais
quand on a des vitres qui sont cassés
même temps tombé du chauffage
malheureusement ça suffit pas son temps
un mistral et comme on a souvent du
mistral à marseille
c'est vrai que ça de vrai problème
l'école présente bien quelques problèmes
mais tout le monde s'accorde à dire
qu'elle n'est pas la pire
le convoi décide d'aller dans celles les
plus cités par la presse direction
l'école kallisté située dans une des
cités les plus sensibles des quartiers
nord et les parents d'élèves sont
présents pour dire tout le bien qu'il
pense de la municipalité la ville alors
oui monsieur koné c'est vraiment la
dégradation alors monsieur côté il
arrête de donner aux cartes issues de la
base et vient pour quartiers nord kalisa
existons pays comme tout le monde va
avoir sur les gens que je connais et tu
te bouges me font le trou du cul là si
vous voulez coupé vous complètement bas
les bons mots il y aussi et il vient
voir ce qu'il ya des pointures affaires
et des travaux à faire
elle est à d'autres alors vous êtes venu
parce que vous savez qu'il y avait des
gens la liste non monsieur
non c'est moi ici encore peu de problème
visible parents d'élèves et élus
dénonçant le fait qu'il s'agit de la
maternelle voisine qui accumule les
problèmes et non cette école élémentaire
en pleines vacances scolaires la mairie
arguant qu'elle n'a pas les clés les
journalistes sont donc priés de rester
derrière le portail avant de se diriger
vers la dernière étape
devant l'école jean perrin celle-là même
où enseigne et charlotte magri qui a
écrit à la ministre
là aussi les parents d'élèves sont
présents et des travaux ils en ont bien
vu mais juste avant la visite des
journalistes ou d'un week-end ils sont
venus faire quelques travaux et les
loyers oui les jeunes on habite tous ici
donc ça peut être constaté ils sont
venus ils ont fait appel à des agents de
maintenance pour venir nettoyer et faire
les petits travaux pour soit à en
montrer que nos écoles sont propres mais
vous allez voir la réalité monsieur
voilà le directeur mais nous et sert
bien sûr le problème donc on est un
problème on est là avec nos enfants on
connaît les problèmes qu'à des non
messieurs autres et nous les problèmes
mesdames messieurs les journalistes à la
ce que nous avons voulu faire c'est une
visite de presse la presse peut en effet
constater les différents problèmes dans
l'école comme des trous importants au
sol et des fenêtres qui ne s'ouvre plus
le dialogue entre le représentant
finalement dépêché par la mairie et les
parents d'élèves sont venus là que vous
êtes dans cette victoire ici c'est
l'école de madame magri vous pouvez
c'est l'école oublier un même chez les
cols de la dame qui a fait sa lettre par
conséquent vous avez sa classe vous
pouvez voir ce qu'ils ratent qui va pas
dans sa classe vous pouvez vous rendre
compte par vous même et vous pouvez voir
si si vraiment l'expression la honte de
la république est fondée
d'ouvrir les écoles des feuilles la
république et le directeur général des
services a bien du mal à expliquer la
présence de nappes en papier sur les
murs des éléments sur la pédagogie
qu'est ce que vous répondez
est ce que les professeurs peuvent pas
faire la place lamentant du temps qui se
rencontraient réparer la peinture
refaire la peinture
bien entendu qu'il faut regarder
la visite de parler parce qu'il veut
parler donc en menant directement on est
venu pouvoir monsieur donc si c'est ça
comme vous l'avez a montré à la presse
ça va pas bien loin en alertant les
parents d'élèves samia ghali a réussi à
transformer l'exercice de communication
de la mairie en un fiasco total
l'état lui non plus n'a pas apprécié le
déni de la mairie la ministre de
l'éducation nationale et celui de la
ville ont donc saisi la préfecture et
l'inspection académique pour un réel
inventaire de la situation les deux
institutions vont travailler d'urgence
sur ce dossier pas une mise sous tutelle
mais une surveillance rapprochée pour la
mairie le principe de la libre
administration des collectivités
territoriales n'est pas remise en cause
par notre travail
donc la responsabilité des écoles
incombe bien la ville de marseille notre
mission c'est d'être aux côtés de la
mairie de marseille pour faire en sorte
que cette mission soit rempli le mieux
possible et réellement nous sommes en
appui nous sommes en a pu mais nous ne
faisons pas à la place des alertes ont
été lancées
je pense que ces alertes n'ont peut-être
pas eu suffisamment d'écho c'est ce que
l'on constate aujourd'hui que notre
attention même si elle a été grande
au titre de nos deux institutions n'a
peut-être pas été suffisamment grande
et je crois que pour reprendre les
propos que vous évoquiez tout à l'heure
la lettre de des deux ministres
rappellent aujourd'hui l'état doit être
d'une vigilance absolue par rapport à la
situation c'est un état des lieux
officiels doit donc être fait mais pas
question pour les élus d'attendre sans
rien faire dont les 15e et 16e
arrondissements samia ghali veut faire
son propre inventaire la sénatrice maire
convoque un conseil d'arrondissement
extraordinaire sur les écoles parents
d'élèves et enseignants de ce secteur
sont appelés à témoigner
ça m est finalement d'avoir aussi votre
expertise vous les habitants et
professionnels en cours en cela je
dirais le milieu enseignant et des
équipes pédagogiques
mais alors ça devrait être un droit pour
nos arbres à on n'est plus dans une
logique de réflexion et d'anticipation
des problèmes sur le territoire c'est à
dire que tout ce qu on voir millions de
voix en pleine face on voit que les
budgets qui sanglotait pour les écoles
va redescendre par où va l'argent
parce que là on a quand même des
dysfonctionnements qui sont majeurs
c'est dire si on les bat des cils et
rires on ne l'était pas et on la charte
pour la paix et s'illustre connaît on va
finir enfin la route du bois hariez
centrale au pied droit
ce qu'il faut un véritable inventaire à
la prévert de tous les problèmes et donc
ont signé et envoyé à la mairie centrale
sous forme de questions écrites
l'obligeront à apporter une réponse
qu'elle ne peut se faire sans la
population et la population ne peut rien
faire sans les élus je crois que c'est
le fait qu'on soit tous ensemble moi
c'est ma conception de la vie politique
c'est que c'est que les habitants sont
avec nous dans les combats que l'on mène
pour être sûr de mener les vrais combats
et les bons combats
emporter l'adhésion des habitants dans
son combat c'est aussi l'objectif du
sénateur maire fn du secteur voisin dont
les 13e et 14e arrondissements
stéphane ravier fait donc la tournée des
écoles avec son équipe il faut demander
à la ville de marseille s'était moqué au
prochain conseil municipal mais c'est
simplement évoqué il ya des études n'y a
toujours rien de concret concernant nos
conditions là ils sont en train de nous
la faire comme on est chez nous à
l'envers sans trop faire de l'enfumage
sur le terrain devant cette école qui ne
disposent pas de dortoir et qui en
réclame 1 depuis des années la pétition
rencontre un franc succès des
marseillais
comprenez bien qu'il s'agit pas d'une
démarche politicienne et électoraliste
ac c'est rassembleur on va dire c'est
dans l'intérêt de tous les enfants quels
qu'ils soient
quelques quartiers qu'ils soient
et pour ça rassure les parents ce qu'ils
sont ils sont au courant de ce qui ce
qui se passe dans les écoles dans quel
état sont les écoles de leurs enfants
tout ce que nous souhaitons c'est que la
mairie centrale décentralise les moyens
et le personnel pour faire ces travaux
pour répondre aux attentes et d'aller
dans les meilleurs délais or la mairie
centrale est bien est une mairie qui
centralise tous et qui sclérosent tout
depuis trop d'années elle est coupée des
réalités
une proposition inenvisageable pour la
mairie centrale non à l'amérique
danièle casanova adjointe chargée des
écoles veut au contraire montrer qu'on
est loin d'être inactif dont le 3e
arrondissement par exemple une nouvelle
école a vu le jour l'an dernier nous
avons été obligés d'offrir ce nouveau
groupe scolaire très rapidement et un
contrôleur en dur sa demande deux ans de
marchés publics même trois quelque fois
et il a fallu que dans les six mois
on trouve des capacités d'accueil donc
on a construit cette école modulaire au
niveau de ce quartier des casernes
locaux climatisés matériel informatique
en quantité rétroprojecteur dans les
classes tout ll y ait une école qui a
coûté 3 5 millions d'euros à la
municipalité de quoi désengorger un peu
un secteur de la ville saturée mais pour
du temporaire avec des préfabriqués
concrètement ces écoles elles peuvent
tenir combien de temps aux échos t elle
semble de toute façon ici il va y avoir
un nouveau quartier sur 150 hectares
avec trois écoles en dur mais en
attendant de réaliser ce nouveau
quartier sur qui va changer complètement
la halle ce site ici nous allons pouvoir
profiter au moins pendant une dizaine
d'années de ses classes en préfabriqué
face à la difficulté de trouver des
terrains la ville a aussi eu l'occasion
de récupérer un lycée dans le 4e
arrondissement jean claude gaudin
l'avait même inauguré en grande pompe à
la rentrée 2015 transformé pour des
jeunes écoliers il fait la fierté de la
municipalité et la mosaïque on a vendu
garder aussi je trouve que c'est très
c'est très beau
on montre donc la mairie bouche et après
les premières réactions de dénis sur la
situation des écoles on reconnaît
désormais que oui des dysfonctionnements
existait bel et bien et on tente d'y
répondre
on va mettre un numéro vert destiné
exclusivement aux directeurs d'école et
ça sera le allô mairie spéciales et cole
qui se chargera de trouver le bon
employé le bon service qui vaudra qui
viendra réparer le problème de cas
signalés directeur d'école je crois que
ça sera un gros progrès parce que ça se
perd des numéros de téléphone
quelquefois le directeur ne gagnait pas
le bon numéro et la réaction n'était pas
aussi rapide que ce qu'on l'aurait
souhaité si la mairie a commencé à
réagir professeurs et directeurs
d'écoles restent mobilisés un collectif
tente de fédérer leurs revendications et
lance les états généraux de l'éducation
là aussi les témoignages affluent même
si les choses ont commencé à bouger dans
les écoles est apparemment dans tous les
sens on sera prêt on arrive avec ses
intentions delà des moyens qui avait
très bien voir les choses et aussi des
fonctionnements améliorée moi ça fait
quatre ans justement d'un organigramme
précis des services de la municipalité
par exemple une petite chose mais c'est
très pratique très concrète qui fait qu'
on n'avance pas je demande des accusés
de réception des mails je n'ai jamais
aussi ça pour dire que peut-être il
faudrait se poser la question du tout
des relations avec les directeurs sont
quand même au quotidien dans lesquels on
compte et la brutalité
ça s'agite dans les écoles on reçoit des
tables qu'on avait commandé il ya trois
ans ou des choses comme ça on ne sent
que la mairie est un peu sous pression
on peut aussi face à chacune de nos
revendications mettre en face le texte
de loi laisse est constitutionnelle on
demande pas la lune
on demande pas quelque chose
d'incroyable on demande le strict
respect des lois
une liste de revendications est adopté
une première démarche avant d'autres
mobilisations à venir c'était une
première étape aujourd'hui qui était
intéressante de par la diversité des
personnes qui étaient qui étaient là
qu'elle soit du premier ou du second
degré aussi de par la diversité
géographique puisque avait des personnes
qui venaient du centre de marseille qui
menait de l'est du nord de marseille est
donc cette première base si vous voulez
va essayer de faire tache ville un petit
peu pour continuer à construire un
rapport de force et pour que vraiment
soir mesure est de contraindre les
personnes qui nous oublie face à cette
agitation tous azimuts des élus et des
professeurs la mairie consent finalement
à faire des efforts
le conseil municipal du 1er avril est
donc l'occasion de passer au rattrapage
pour la ville des travaux sont votés et
des fonds supplémentaires débloqués
c'est le grand jean où c'est de
l'esbrouffe réputé ya ce qui va être
votée ensuite il ya la mise en oeuvre
donc
prend acte de ce que va faire son appel
maire de marseille je reconnais et donc
il a fini par reconnaître que ce que
j'avais dit finalement j'avais raison
sur les écoles marseillaise et la
situation des écoles marseillaises
aujourd'hui les cours les rapports qui
vont passer au conseil municipal
j'espère qu'ils seront suivies d'effet
dans les travaux parce que je savais
c'est pas la première fois qu'on voit
des rapports passés pour pour autant au
niveau pas spécialement les travaux
arrivée de votre gestion financière
l'anc est ourdi par le snuipp et paix
france syndicat proche du parti de
gauche a été remise mercredi au service
de l'état
malgré les appels réitérés et insistants
de ce syndicat auprès des enseignants
pour qu'ils dénoncent la moindre dalles
de plafond manquantes ou le col le
carreau soulevés dans les 3500 casse
marseillaise 187 écoles seulement sur
les 444 ont signalé de cartes quelques
dysfonctionnements soit 42%
chacun peut conclure que dans 58% des
écoles soit 257 64 144 les enseignants
sont satisfaits de l'état des locaux et
les actes ce sont les délibérations
d'aujourd'hui que vous nous présentez et
elle signe un terrible désaveu oui un
terrible désaveu pour le chef de votre
majorité
car alors que tout va bien madame la
marquise dans le meilleur des mondes on
dépêche en urgence des travaux ici et là
signe que finalement non tout ne va pas
bien il est certain qu ici ou là sans
doute il y avait des travaux qui
auraient dû peut-être être fait qui 12
ans peut échapper
il aurait suffi aux il aurait suffi
qu'on nous le dise vieux de manière
qu'on nous le dise du de manière peu
direct bon pouvoir effectivement on a
envie de répondre puisque nous l'avons
fait immédiatement
nous avons dépêché des équipes qui ont
travaillé effectivement d'une manière
très forte pendant les vacances qui
comme diderot à le faire d'ailleurs
pendant ces vacances de pâques nous
avons repris immédiatement un certain
nombre de décisions qui s'imposaient au
total mes chers collègues se 105
millions d'euros supplémentaires qui
seront alloués aux travaux dans les
écoles
l'enveloppé totale l'investissement pour
étant un supporter et j'en remercie
l'adjoint aux finances bien entendu qui
a prévu tout cela de 36 millions d'euros
à 40 millions d'euros
et cet effort je le rappelle sera
reconduit en 2017 et 2018 5 millions
d'euros sur trois ans qui permettent
d'envisager des travaux d'urgence dans
les établissements les vacances d'avril
sont déjà l'occasion d'engager une
partie de ces fonds dédié aux écoles
si ce projet de rénovation étaient déjà
lancés avant la polémique
il illustre l'engagement de la ville
pour doc en résumé l'étanchéité des
toitures et c'est face à ces dernières
la dépose avec ses pattes avant
vous allez préfabriqués tout ça va où là
cette semaine il nous reste plus qu'à
terminer et les menuiseries l'isolation
thermique par l'extérieur plus les
bardages on l'a notre priorité nous
c'est de finir donc les façades avant la
rentrée des classes de tout ce qu'il y
ait isolation thermique plaquages des
salles qui prenait l'eau sont donc
rénové ici pour cent mille euros et la
rallonge budgétaire permettra
d'accélérer les chantiers ici l'eau
arrivait elle rentrer à l'intérieur
c'est ce qui me l'a tous pourris donc il
faut à tout prix quand on puisse c'était
vieux mai
aujourd'hui il faut à tout prix ce soir
est atteint puisque les directives de
monsieur le maire s'était de démarrer au
plus tôt nous ce genre de choses bien
sûr qu'on a on a la possibilité de
réagir assez vite puisqu'on a des
travaux qui sont programmés puis à ceux
qui ne le sont pas qu'ils sont prévues
pour les suivantes
donc parfois quand on a une opportunité
comme celle-là mais ça nous permet 9
d'avancé une programmation d'une des
travaux engagés des fonds débloqués ne
manque plus que la grande réconciliation
entre le gouvernement et la mairie
elle interviendra le 18 avril presque
main dans la main jean claude gaudin et
najat vallaud belkacem enterrent la
hache de guerre sur le terrain et après
les 5 millions d'euros par an de la
mairie c'est au tour de la ministre de
sortir le carnet de chèques
l'état a décidé de débloquer une
enveloppe de 5 millions d'euros au titre
des crédits de la politique de la ville
c'est une démarche qui se veut
exemplaire qui nous permet de sortir de
cette situation par le haut dans
laquelle l'état et la ville de marseille
travaille ensemble
au total ce sont donc 10 millions
supplémentaires par an qui sont
débloqués au vu du retard pris et du
nombre d'écoles à reconstruire ou à
rénover le chantier risque bien de
prendre des années et des années